l'appel à charlotte à la qualité y est
l'apparence et le calibre exigé par les
grossistes sont à peu près respectées
mais le gros point noir c'est la
quantité de tubercules dans le sol le
ronronnement et entre 20 et 25 % en
moins par rapport aux années normal donc
suite gros coup de chaud qu'on a pu
avoir des rocco chaud c'est même pire
que ça ce sont le coup de chalumeau
qu'on ait pu avoir ça bloquait la verità
sion
dans ce hangar de stockage réfrigéré 600
tonnes de pommes de terre ans déjà et
est rentrée il y en aura 2000
l'équivalent d'un jour de consommation à
paris à la fin de la campagne
d'arrachage 2000 tonnes dont une partie
pourrait ne pas être commercialisé les
acheteurs en gros ont demandé un délai
d'observation
avec les conditions climatiques on a pu
avoir dans la conservation on ne sait
pas on sait pas ce que ça va donner ça
peut être très bien come on come ça peut
avec un peu tombé en en pourriture elle
peut elle peut se dégrader parce qu'avec
le froid avec les différentes variance
que de température qu'on va avoir eh
bien vous ne connaît pas on sait pas son
avenir soit la contre le terrorisme
aujourd'hui il y a dix mille hectares
plantés en beauce et plus de 450
producteurs de pommes de terre il y en
aura sans doute mois l'an prochain car
il ya un troisième écueil l'explosion
des coûts de production entre le plan
entre les phyto de protection de
cultures l'irrigation l'énergie
électrique un la conservation de la
pomme de terre et la main d'oeuvre pour
le triage aujourd'hui on est sur 9000
euros l'hectare c'est exorbitant on peut
dire 10 ha c'est 90000 euros pour un
producteur aujourd'hui il n'a pas cette
trésorerie là pour éviter une forte
baisse des surfaces l'union des
planteurs demandant qu'à l'état un
soutien financier exceptionnel c'est un
nouveau dossier sur le bureau du
ministre de l'agriculture marc fesneau